on this episode I talk about my pops I'd
rule someone directly in a face for a
crap question and I really focus on what
small businesses should be doing with
itsy-bitsy cash hello everybody and
welcome to episode three of hashtag
askgaryvee I'm really enjoying the show
I hope you are as well and let's get
right into question number one but first
actually you know what we do I'm gonna
do a tidbit about every number the
number three my favorite roulette number
it's my mom's birthday I love you mom
Brandon asks hey Gary Vee what are the
most important lessons your father Sasha
taught you about building a business you
know Sasha has taught me a bunch of
stuff some that I like to keep some that
I kind of pushed to the side right dad
uh you know this is a very easy question
for me who asked that question Brandon
lovely Brandon brand that's very easy
this my dad taught me word is bond I've
said a couple times for the people that
watch me a lot they know this that when
I walked into my dad's business at 14
let's just say I was a little bit of a
[ __ ] artist and you know a lot of
the charisma and the showmanship and the
salesmanship that a lot of you enjoy and
I appreciate that also comes with being
full of crap it's got a very similar
cousin DNA and I'm glad I got very lucky
let's call it what it is I do not think
I'd be as honorable or as good of a dude
without my dad's correction of you make
I never forget it you make a commitment
you buy 50 when I started buying wine
you buy 50 cases no matter what you take
those 50 cases if you say I'll take 50
cases if the market changes if it gets
an 84 in the Wine Spectator you take it
you eat it you drink it your word is
bonded because I play the marathon not
the sprint long term businessman that's
helped me a lot because I've kept
relationships forever because sticking
to it has mattered quite a bit so thanks
dad and thanks Brandon for the question
Jeff
where do you see yourself in five years
Jeff the truth is I don't really see
myself anywhere in five years I am NOT a
planner I do not have a five-year plan I
think all of us can agree that five
years ago Instagram and snapchat didn't
exist you know GoPro I mean just like
you know Netflix wasn't what it is today
I mean the world is changing way too
much for me to think where I'm going to
be in five years professionally five
years personally I will be in better
shape I will spend more time with my
family I will be going to a lot of
lacrosse games and and ballets and shows
and just trying to hack my life to have
a better balance professionally I will
be doing what I always do
d-roc zoom in on this year I want you to
go right in there my friend
this ear will be listening to the
marketplace I will be listening to the
marketplace and it will be adjusting on
the fly in real time and I will be
running a business and marketing like
it's 2017 like at 2019 like it's 2022
like it's 2027
I'm a reactionary what I like to call I
am a halftime adjustments head coach my
game plan is okay going into the game
I'm down twenty one two three at
halftime 15 minutes I reverse drop down
flip it and reverse it
I come out and I win 27 24 that is who I
am as an entrepreneur that is why I have
no idea what I will be doing or how I
see myself professionally in five years
then asks heading to New York City for
the first time in September
what wine bar restaurant would you
recommend Ben thanks for the props on
rezzie's zoom indie-rock any of these
lovely establishments that have been
smart enough to join the fray Gotham bar
grill rosemarys Minetta tavern Toro
Stella Charlie bird Balthazar all great
choices so I highly recommend that and
off the app as a wine bar I'm a huge
terroir fan stunwin you're in the wine
game a little bit quite a bit you're
passionate any wine bars you kind of a
come a little face time buzz yes love
her yeah you know to me it's its terroir
cork buzz those are two spots to most
focus on Scott asks what's your number
one piece of advice
for marketing a lean local city based
social startup when we asked for more
details who responded that the product
isn't fully developed however its social
marketing for my city only Scotty listen
I took this question because you tweeted
that you wouldn't eat until I answered
your question and knowing that eating is
important I wanted to deliver for you
but I've got to be honest with you and I
love you brother and your walk you know
who I am you're watching the show so you
asked the question I hate your question
it's a ludicrous thing to think about at
this point because the products not even
developed yet you're worried about
marketing I'd love for you to develop
the product taste it a little bit kind
of back to question number two or three
where you know it's you know you've got
to feel it you've got to put it out in
the wild reverse-engineer it a little
bit you know your you know my city only
like local there's a ton of things you
can do Facebook to our post tweets
geolocation stuff there's a ton of
things to do mobile ads stuff there's
just an enormous amount of flexibility
on how to drill it with a local business
but the truth is you're getting ahead of
yourself this is you know I don't want
to dismember Zen we go and I don't want
to disk because I love you it's a little
bit of an amateurish question I need you
to kind of get the app out or the
product out you're just getting way too
ahead of yourself the marketing will
matter only if the product is
serviceable at some level I mean great
products always need less great
marketing and great marketing doesn't
fix crap products what's your advice for
small business owners with limited
budgets is it some local listings in SEO
writing content social media Antoine
what's up brother Gary be up but you
know uh you know look this is always the
best question this is the question that
I rappelled with rappelled uh grappled
with you know when I got involved in my
dad's business it's very hard what do
you do like I made flyers at home and
gave them out when people walked into
the store when you're hustling and
you've got limited budget you're in
trouble by many people's points of view
let me give you the real first answer
the real first answer is work more the
greatest way to close the gap
financially is to put in the extra two
or three hours so whenever you're doing
an hour two to each day still eat
healthy still have sleep but an hour two
of hustle a little less watching Game of
Thrones marathons and Madden 15 you know
extra hustle because when you're limited
that's the play to me Facebook dark
posts has one of the best ROI is right
now Google AdWords is always a strong
contender
you know banner retargeting it really
depends on your business it depends on
your e-commerce to me those three would
really work if you're a local business
is trying to drive people into the score
you start looking at Yelp and for
squares and things of that nature
sometimes it might even be Believe It or
Not local radio local cable television
believe it or not there might be ways
but the truth is there's very specific
answers based on very specific small
businesses but don't don't lack hustle
bizdev one of my favorite things when we
to have a lot of dollars was Deb go to
the barber and be like can I put some
flyers in my of my business in your
store and you can put some you know
there's that move there's the call for
advertisers thing that was my classic
YouTube video we can link that down
below
that's probably second time in three
episodes linking it but it's a classic
it's go and get the money and so those
would be my first answers to a local
financially strapped networking hustling
biz Devon go to the local business
around you trade go to the Chamber of
Commerce events figure out if you can do
something and just print coupons and
hand them out you know in quotes guys I
appreciate you jamming with me in
episode 3 really enjoying this I haven't
done a regular show since 2011 I'm
enjoying myself quite a bit if you want
to ask me a question use the hashtag ask
Gary Vee on Twitter and we'll get you on
the show it should be your life dream to
get your question on the show you with a
little bit of me we are changing the QA
world